herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
mario puls4 wie aaron edge 13 städte in
der östlichen ukraine im don was die
nach langen grausamen kämpfen von der
russischen armee besetzt worden sind tag
lang bestimmten sie die nachrichten
jetzt allerdings ist es etwas still
etwas ruhig um sie geworden seitdem sie
in russischer hand sense aber wie ist
die situation dort wie sehen die städte
jetzt aus wie ist die lage wie geht es
den menschen dort wir bekommen heute
einen besonderen einen seltenen aber
sehr wichtigen einblick denn ein zdf
kamerateam mit unserem reporter wienand
wernicke war das erste deutsche fernseh
team was dort in der sie diese situation
hat drehen können unter russischer
besatzung wernicke war mit seinem team
als embedded journalist mit der
russischen armee unterwegs also als
journalist der ständig von vertretern
des russischen verteidigungsministeriums
umgeben war kontrolliert wurde also
nicht ganz frei berichten konnte bei der
viertägigen fahrt wurde er wurden er und
sein team also an orte geführt zu
situationen gebracht die eben gefilmt
werden sollten die nach einem plan des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
gefilmt werden sollten doch auch wenn
alles vorherbestimmt war kontrolliert
wurde auch wenn die handwerker als
korrespondent als reporter aufgrund
russischer gesetze das wort krieg oder
invasion nicht in den mund nehmen kann
ohne in allergrößte schwierigkeiten zu
kommen trotz all dieser probleme war es
eben eine chance einen einblick zu
bekommen und wir wollen jetzt mit
wieland werke über seine eindrücke über
diese reise sprechen wenn es fragen gibt
einfach her damit wir sind alle
gemeinsam gespannt auf die antworten von
wienand erstmal größe jetzt nach moskau
das klingt ja alles nach einer reise die
ja doch ziemlich speziell besonders war
und alles andere als ein ganz normaler
reportage drehen
ja das ist nicht alltag im bett zu
arbeiten wie man das kurz sagt am bett
zu arbeiten das ist nicht alltag für uns
und du hast gesagt gehabt ist
normalerweise auch nicht der anspruch
den man hat weil man ja die reportage
reise die organisation alles selbst
übernimmt die orte wo man hinfährt aber
in dem fall ist es glaube ich trotzdem
angebracht gewesen und es war auch nicht
so als wenn wir lange versucht hätten
das zu machen sondern das russische
verteidigungsministerium ist auf uns
zugekommen hat gefragt ob wir diese
reise begleiten wollen es gab wenn ich
das richtig weiß bereits 7 seit ist
diesen schweren konflikt gibt sieben
solcher reisen von moskau aus mit
journalistinnen und journalisten
bloggerinnen und bloggern und ähnlichen
das waren in der regel oft kremlnahe
berichterstatter diesmal waren wir halt
dabei und für uns war das dann wirklich
die möglichkeit einen einblick zu
bekommen dann sehen wir schon so einige
bilder wo wart ihr denn genau welche
städte welche orte habt ihr gesehen
wir haben tatsächlich die sachen besucht
die in den nachrichten in den letzten
wochen immer und immer wieder
auftauchten weil der schwere kämpfe
gemeldet wurden das war riesig als das
was theron jetzt das war ein mariupol
wir waren auch hinter und jetzt kommt's
haben also quasi und johanns grund haben
also wirklich diesen bereich bereist wir
sind nicht quasi direkt bis an das
gegangen was man kontakte oder front
nennt aber wir waren sehr dicht dran
mussten halt auch sicherheits aus
sicherheitsausrüstung tragen zum teil
also wir haben genau das gesehen wo die
kämpfe stattgefunden haben und konnten
daher auch einen eindruck gewinnen wie
es den menschen heute geht die da leben
und du sagst also nicht direkt an der
kontakt linie aber hat man eben in
diesen orten legends trotzdem gefühl
bekommen da tobt der krieg was habt ihr
gehört gesehen
also am deutlichsten mitbekommen hat man
es tatsächlich von bin jetzt aus weil
man da die artillerie sehr stark
gehörter tag und nacht das war
tatsächlich sehr sehr intensiv zuhören
in den orten spürt man die den dänen das
was da passiert ist die kämpfe und ganz
besonders dadurch wenn man sieht was das
mit den städten gemacht hat wie gebäude
aussehen wie zerschossen wie zerbombt
sie sind mariupol und die siegchance das
ist ja etwas was dann sehr einprägsam
ist man riecht ist ja auch mal so es ist
alles sehr sehr präsent und da sind dann
halt menschen die da geblieben sind
unter unter bedingungen die natürlich
ganz besonders schwierig sind kein
wasser kein strom keine richtige
lebensmittelversorgung und die da
trotzdem bleiben weil sie ganz oft sagen
wo soll ich denn hin was wäre denn die
alternative was soll ich machen das ist
ja auch meine heimat hier bin ich
aufgewachsen und die deswegen da bleiben
und sich durchschlagen und das zu sehen
allein dafür hat es sich gelohnt und auf
dieses schicksal aufmerksam zu machen
dann sind wir sehr gespannt und wollen
einfach mal einen ausschnitt aus einer
reportage sehen und dann gleich weiter
über die eindrücke reden
embedded eingebettet werden solche drei
reisen genannt einerseits werden wir
hier in der nähe des kampf gebietes von
bewaffneten russischen soldaten
beschützt andererseits werden wir auf
schritt und tritt von vertretern des
verteidigungsministeriums aus moskau
begleitet das ahnen auch die menschen
hier in st und jetzt die in den ruinen
leben und natürlich wegen sie deshalb
genau ihre worte
warum soll ich von hier weggehen das ist
meine stadt ich bin hier geboren ich
lebe hier die ukraine war meine heimat
sie war die ukraine aber ich bin ein
russischsprachiger mensch ich liebe und
spreche russisch
kaputte straßen zerstörte brücken
unbewohnbare orte es ist eine reise in
ein gebiet in welchem wochen lang kämpfe
zwischen russland und der ukraine tobt
in teilen eine ruinenstadt wer überlebte
und blieb hat nun kein wasser keinen
strom und nichts zu essen russland
organisiert hilfe und präsentiert das
unserer kamera wir sind zusammen steht
auf den paketen die botschaft an die
einwohner hier und dann die welt die
zukunft des don was heißt russland
selensky hier das sagen hat oder putin
ist mir völlig egal es darf nur nicht
weiter diese schreckliche situation
geben es soll jetzt nur ruhig bleiben
doch daran glauben wir viele nicht es
herrscht angst vor der zukunft denn die
ukraine will ihre gebiete zurückerobern
und hat eine gegenoffensive angekündigt
die schweren kämpfe können also
zurückkommen es werden waffen
präsentiert mit denen die ukrainische
armee gekämpft hatte darunter systeme
geliefert vom westen eine art trophäe
und psychologische botschaft an die nato
dass auch diese unterstützung der
ukraine nicht helfen würde
es gibt ganz viele fragen die bekommen
wir hier auch schon rein aber fangen wir
erst mal damit an wir haben das jetzt
sehr schön gesehen dass da ganz viele
journalisten um dich drumherum sind oder
zumindest leute mit einer videokamera
smartphone etc erklärt damals sind das
jetzt alles westliche journalisten
gewesen oder russische journalisten wehr
war mit dir da unterwegs
das ist eine gruppe von 30 35 leuten
gewesen da sind eine menge sogenannter
freier journalisten die sich
journalisten bezeichneten dabei auch aus
dem westlichen ausland bloggerinnen und
blogger und ähnliches die in der regel
pro russisch berichten und westliche
medien waren wir wenn ich das ist
richtige drei vertreter die dabei waren
das ist quasi ja etwas was ja dem
verteidigungsministerium in russland
auch klar ist dass sie keine reichweite
generieren wenn sie da die üblichen
verdächtigen mit vor ort haben sondern
dass es natürlich für ihr anliegen was
hier nennen fake news vermeiden ist
wichtig sei dass auch westliche medien
dabei sind und am ende des tages erahnen
sie aber auch schon dass wir natürlich
anders berichten werden als dass viele
von kreml nahen journalisten machen also
dass wir das ganze eher kritisch
einordnen dass wir es auch offenlegen
unter welchen bedingungen wieder
arbeiten das ist transparent ist was wir
können und was wir nicht können und was
unser anspruch ist nämlich zu erkennen
wie menschen leben die in diesen
gebieten geblieben sind und wie die
situation ist aber auch offen legen dass
wir natürlich nicht uns frei bewegen
konnten
reden wir gleich noch über die ziele den
sinn sozusagen aus russischer sicht
warum das ganze organisiert worden ist
aber reden wir erst mal fragen werde ich
erstmal was ist die ist das ding gewesen
mit den menschen zu sprechen konnten die
frei sprechen was war denn dein eindruck
wenn du damit der dame gesprochen hast
die gesagt hat ja das ist meine heimat
das ist die ukraine das war die ukraine
und ich spreche ja russisch die war das
was hast du empfunden
ja also im großen und ganzen ist
natürlich jedem wenn da so ein tross auf
einen zukommt und da sind russische
soldaten dabei die den bewachen und mit
bussen und so weiter ist das natürlich
klar das ist eine offizielle sache es
waren natürlich insofern auch klar dass
diese frau nicht völlig unvorbereitet
da vor dem gebäude stand es gab andere
situationen den musik-charts wo da die
lebensmittel ausgegeben worden und und
wasser da kamen ja die menschen aus dem
ort das waren also keine ausgewählten
statisten oder ähnliches sondern die
kamen weil sie hilfe brauchten und mit
denen haben wir da auch reden können
also insofern das ist eine mischung aus
aus präpariert aber eben auch wirklich
authentisch und insofern kann man ein
bisschen sagen ja klar man muss manchmal
ein bisschen was abziehen von dem was
die leute sagen aber das war auch viel
dabei was sie genau so empfunden haben
also diese dieser wunsch zum beispiel
dass jetzt endlich ruhe sein soll und
das ist ja schon fast egal ist unter
welcher politischen situationen man sich
dann befindet aber bitte kein krieg mehr
das war schon etwas was die leute
wirklich zu empfinden man muss sich aber
auch fragen wer ist denn dann noch da in
diesen völlig zerbombten ortschaften
diejenigen die jetzt gesagt hätten sag
ich mal russians co home oder die
sozusagen wütend auf russische besatzer
gewesen wären die haben ja entweder zur
waffe gegriffen oder sind wahrscheinlich
geflohen oder
ja klar das schon aber du siehst ja auch
wenn du da durch die orte gehst wie
viele ältere herrschaften da sind und
tatsächlich die haben kein geld die
haben auch keine möglichkeit woanders
hinzugehen die haben da ihre wohnung und
vielleicht ihren gatten aber nicht
irgendwo 10.000 euro liegen um irgendwo
weg zu gehen die sind da eigentlich auch
daran gebunden oder etwas jüngere leute
die ihre alten eltern haben wo sollen
die hingehen wie sollen die das
organisieren also da sind viele gegangen
gar keine frage aber es gibt auch viele
gründe für menschen da dann zu bleiben
jetzt kommen die spannende frage für
melanie herzig frag dich warum sprechen
die reporter denn nicht mit den
russischen soldaten auch mal hattet ihr
denn die möglichkeit auch russische
soldaten dort zu fragen
großes soldaten in der ganz normalen
soldaten ebene keine chance dass das das
gibt es nicht es gibt ein paar töne ein
paar statements die von einem
offiziellen presseoffizier gegeben
wurden aber das sind dann wirklich
verlautbarungen de facto die
nicht wirklich weiter bringen das ist
das ist ein ganz offizielles sprech aber
mit soldaten selbst konnten wir gar
nicht reden jetzt direkt zu dem zu
deiner vorletzten antwort sagt mike
fragt mike kreml ist es den leuten da
wirklich egal wer das sagen hat es nicht
warum gerade darüber gesprochen über den
otto wo die frau sagt ist doch egal ob
selensky oder putin hauptsache es ist
ruhe hier also ein bisschen die
kritische frage von my creme ist es
wirklich denen egal was ist dein gefühl
wenn ich glaube es gibt ja kaum einen
menschen der sagen würde es ist mir egal
in was für einem system ich lebe was die
meinen ist dass nach diesen wochen nach
dem was wir erlebt haben nach diesen
bombardements und nach dem hin und her
nachdem alles zerschossen worden ist
dass sie ruhe haben wollen das ist dass
es sozusagen ihnen ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass das nicht noch mal kommt das meint
dass also natürlich meint es nicht im
endeffekt ist es mir völlig wurscht aber
diese diese die diese verzweiflung über
das was sie in den letzten wochen erlebt
haben die kann man daraus lesen und
gleich die nächste ja sehr gute
spannende frage von thomas k wurden denn
die raw aufnahmen also das was ihr
gedreht hat und auch die anderen aber du
kannst ja jetzt mal ganz konkret von dir
reden wurden den ich jetzt dein ganzes
material vor der ausstrahlung also bevor
ihr das jetzt die reportage fertig
gemacht hat wurde das von der russischen
armee in irgendeiner art und weise
kontrolliert
nein überhaupt nicht da gab es
tatsächlich keine kontrollen ist man
hatte schon das gefühl dass hin und
wieder die sache mit rumgelaufen sind
wenn wir interviews geführt haben dass
da versucht wurde ein bisschen zuzuhören
aber es gab keine kontrolle wir mussten
kein material vorlegen das wäre dann
übrigens auch ein grund gewesen
tatsächlich dann wären wir auch nicht
gereist das also wenn das eine
voraussetzung gewesen wäre wenn so eine
form von zensur stattgefunden hätte
wären wir auch nicht mit gefahren das
ist gar keine frage insofern das
material haben wir so gedreht und dann
so verarbeitet wie ist ausgestrahlt
wurde wir kommen noch gleichauf weitere
punkte aber ulrike fragt was soll so
eine reportage bringen jeder mit
verstand weiß doch dass alles in szene
gesetzt worden ist du hast ja gerade so
angedeutet es ist
ja nicht ein stück weit sondern es ist
einfach ein kompromiss und man muss
überlegen wie weit geht man bei diesem
kompromiss wie würdest du jetzt
antworten
ja dass nicht alles in szene gesetzt
werden kann was da ist also das was ich
sehe das was ich sehe wenn ich über die
straßen fahren wenn ich sehe dass die
ganzen brücken kaputt sind wenn alle
straßen weg sind fassaden weggesprengt
dass da kein wirkliches leben mehr
möglich ist dass ist ja nicht inszeniert
sondern das ist eine situation mit der
die menschen die da sind umgehen müssen
wo man bei mehreren tönen ein bisschen
abziehen muss es wenn da jemand auf ihn
gewartet hat der ein interview gibt klar
gar keine frage aber ich habe es ja
gerade schon gesagt es gibt eine menge
situation in die wir auch gekommen sind
wo menschen tatsächlich vorbeigekommen
sind die wir angesprochen haben das aber
nicht alle geantwortet das macht aber
auch in moskau auf der straße oder in
berlin auf der straße nicht jeder aber
insofern ist es ein kompromiss klar da
sind sachen inszeniert aber weiß gott
nicht alles jetzt ist ja gerade das
hervorragende dass du nun jahrelang auch
korrespondent in moskau war es dass du
dort im don was eben ja auch schon
öfters war es beschreibt auch einfach
mal wie war das denn bei deinen reisen
früher vor vielen jahren der krieg dort
anders als bei den menschen in odessa in
lemberg in kiew hat ja für die menschen
im sonntaz nicht jetzt
vierundzwanzigster februar 2022 begonnen
sondern 2014 was macht das denn mit den
menschen und wie erlebst du das
ja das ist tatsächlich etwas was in der
öffentlichkeit gern so ein bisschen
vergessen wird da wird jetzt auf 400
monate geschaut aber es ist ja völlig
richtig das dauert ja viel viel länger
für die menschen im don was das ist eine
lange lange zeit und das macht natürlich
irgendwie auch müde das macht etwas
abgestumpft das macht so schrecklich das
klingt aber eine form von gewöhnung was
da wirklich auch leute erzählen ist dass
selbst bei den schlimmsten alarmen die
leute auch trotzdem noch ausgegangen
sind irgendwie wasser zu besorgen weil
es irgendwie zum alltag gehört es ist
eine eine situation das mag man sich gar
nicht vorstellen wenn das über jahre
immer die den alltag und das leben
beschäftigt man stelle sich vor man hat
kinder die in der region aufwachsen
ja wir haben das mehrfach wirklich viele
viele viele male besucht die kolleginnen
und kollegen die hier im studio moskau
arbeiten und gearbeitet haben waren vor
ort
das ist etwas was was einprägt und was
man was man wirklich mitnimmt weil das
für uns in europa in zentraleuropa kaum
vorstellbar ist dass über so lange zeit
etwas da so passiert
man muss sich halt noch mal vor augen
halten 2014 bis 2022 ist eben eine lange
lange zeit wir haben ihm den in dem
beitrag in den teil dieser reportage von
dir jetzt auch gesehen dass ihr erzählt
sie dass die russischen truppen dort
eben auch erbeutete westliche waffen
euch gezeigt haben was ist denn deiner
meinung nach wohl das ziel gewesen was
soll da die message sozusagen sein
ich glaube das sind zwei effekte die man
sich davon verspricht es der eine ist an
die an die menschen die dort leben und
da geblieben sind quasi ihnen zu zeigen
guckt mal wir erobern das wir kriegen
das hin egal was der westen macht das
ist quasi eine vielleicht als als
vertrauensbildende maßnahme an die
menschen vor ort gemeint wir haben das
im griff und das andere ist natürlich
irgendwie auch eine botschaft an den
westen an die nato nach dem motto egal
was ihre liefert wir gewinnen gefechte
wir werden am ende vielleicht auch diese
gesamte auseinandersetzung gewinnen das
ist so ein psychologisches moment um
dass er dabei ist und das sich zum teil
eben auch richtung westen orientiert
was man euch auch gezeigt hat ich kann
es schon mal vorweg nehmen ist noch eine
andere ganz ganz wichtige sache nicht
nur erbeutete waffen westlicher bauart
sondern man wir alle wissen es eben auch
dass ein punkt der ganz ganz wichtig
eben auch ist es keine waffe sondern
eben getreide die getreideexporte 20
millionen tonnen getreide
lagern in der ukraine können nicht
verschifft werden wegen der seeblockade
der
allergrößte probleme und dann ist da
eben auch etwas gezeigt worden und das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal anderen müssen
darüber reden
blauer himmel gelbes getreide die
nationalfarben der ukraine aber hier
wird mittlerweile unter russischer
flagge gemäht seit wochen wird weltweit
darüber diskutiert ob getreide und damit
hunger zur kriegswaffe wird weil
absichtlich zu wenig exportiert wurde
russland bestreitet das in diesem
agrarbetrieb im osten rechnet man mit
einer guten ernte
am tag nach der ernte verkaufen wir über
händler in russland und sie verkaufen es
in die türkei nach syrien nach ägypten
und sicher nach algerien aber genau weiß
ich das nicht
[Musik]
die russische hymne in der
stadtverwaltung vom militär ausgegeben
werden neue pässe russische pässe im
schnellverfahren das verfügte präsident
putin und ein russischer pass ist ihr
mittlerweile wichtig für die rente ist
das dokument nötig wie soll ich denn
sonst leben ich liebe allein ohne
ehemann mein sohn es im ausland er lebt
in deutschland
im herbst soll es nun ein referendum
geben ob die region um die aufnahme in
die russische föderation bittet ob bis
dahin die kämpfe im donbass beendet sind
scheint angesichts der militärischen und
politischen lage zweifelhaft für die
menschen bleiben ist also gefährliche
zeiten
bin dann über die pässe müssen wir auch
noch reden fangen wir erstmal an mit dem
getreide was wir da gesehen haben damit
also wird gemäht getreide wird also
geerntet und soll also der welt zur
verfügung gestellt werden was was will
denn russland damit demonstrieren was
ist die botschaft
es ist schon das ist schon skurril wenn
man da durch den don was fährt das sind
ja wirklich immer der faktor stunden
lang fährt man ja durch durch felder mit
getreide und mit sonnenblumen es ist
erntezeit dem getreide ist völlig egal
ob frieden ist oder ob eine militärische
sonderoperation umläuft das muss jetzt
halt geerntet werden und das passiert
die kolchosen die landwirtschaftlichen
betriebe die da im osten sind sind jetzt
dabei das wird eine relativ gute ernte
das haben wir uns alle bestätigt die
frage ist halt nur wo das jetzt hingeht
also wir reden jetzt von dem bereich der
von der russischen föderation
kontrolliert wird wo geht das getreide
hin früher wurde es auch richtungen
richtung westen geliefert das wurde uns
auch so erzählt mittlerweile geht es
eben an händler in der russischen
föderation und daneben ein so genannte
befreundete länder da ist zum beispiel
syrien dabei algerien dabei das ist
schon ein druckmittel was man uns da so
ein bisschen gezeigt hat dass es möglich
ist mit getreide eben auch den oder den
fluss des getreides zu steuern aber er
kommt zumindest auf den markt das wurde
wurde da auch klar ob das allerdings
auch wirklich dann die gesamten bestände
sein werden das wird man am ende der
saison vielleicht eher besser wissen
bis jetzt haben wir eben auch gesehen
ukraine was die eben den russischen pass
bekommen eben auch haben wollen um dann
eben rente beziehen zu können franz
isaac oder einzelne gefragt eben wie
sieht denn die zustimmung zu russland im
donbass aus heißt das irgendwie man ist
dann froh dass da befreier kommen und
man jetzt in russischen pass bekommt
oder machen die menschen dass ernst
einfach weil es sonst eben kein essen
gibt und keine rente
ja beides wahrscheinlich am ende des
tages es wird natürlich gibt es menschen
die die auch in diesen postsowjetischen
gedanken sind und die quasi die die
rückkehr zum zum russischen pass als
etwas sowjetisches erleben dass das
wirkt jetzt erst auf den ersten blick
komisch aber das ist dass es bei manchen
wirklich die denke gerade bei älteren
menschen und bei denen ist natürlich
auch der punkt wenn sie dann den pass
nicht haben würden sie die rente nicht
bekommen also es ist halt natürlich auch
manchmal etwas
unabänderliches wenn man wenn man quasi
nicht zur arbeit geht unter einen lohn
bekommt muss man sich halt anpassen
dadurch ist das vielleicht eine mischung
aus beiden
ganz zum schluss einfach noch mal dein
eindruck wie kann man das ganze
bezeichnet ist das propaganda wenn man
sieht da werden hilfsgüter verteilt
nahrungsmittel ja man könnte ja bald
sagen die russischen truppen inszenieren
sich als humanitäre helfer aber will die
russische seite damit vergessen machen
wer den krieg begonnen hat wer
geschossen hat und eben auch die häuser
zerstört hat
also diese form von embedded
journalismus ist ja keine erfindung der
russischen föderation das gibt es ja
schon lange und das machen viele armeen
die sich in solchen konflikten befinden
dass sie journalisten mitnehmen um zu
zeigen was vor ort passiert
dass russland natürlich dabei bestimmte
dinge zeigen will eine form von
normalität in diesen gebieten unbenommen
das ist natürlich so dass sie
tatsächlich da auch humanitäre hilfe
leisten müssen weil dann nämlich nichts
anderes ist da gibt es nichts zu essen
und kein strom und kein wasser auch
unbenommen sonst hätten ihnen menschen
nämlich gar nichts dass sie das vor
unserer kamera und natürlich
präsentieren hat was mit
öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu tun das ist das
ist das ist völlig klar es ändert aber
nichts daran dass es tatsächlich
notwendig ist für die menschen sonst
nicht hätten
ganz ganz herzlichen dank für deine
schilderungen die eindrücke die wir eben
auch zusammen mit deinen bildern gesehen
haben vielen vielen dank und weiterhin
alles gute beim berichten wir wollen
jetzt darüber reden über diese tour
diese im bett journalist uhr die wienand
gemacht hat mit frau dr margarete klein
von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik in berlin
sie ist russland expertin aber auch
expertin für sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik grüße nach berlin
und vielen dank dass sie sich zeit
genommen haben er kenne frau dr klein
was sagen sie denn zu dieser tour dieser
embedded tour unseres reporters was
macht das oder warum macht die russische
seite das ganze ja sie möchte
botschaften senden an das deutsche und
westeuropäische oder europäische
publikum und ist in zwei botschaften
sehr klar geworden dass eine ist dass es
angeblich ziemlich egal sein wer dort
herrschen würde hauptsache der krieg
endet wobei man ja vergisst dass der
krieg von russland begonnen wurde und
russland für diese zerstörungen
verantwortlich ist und das zweite was
gezeigt wird ist das eigentlich egal ist
wenn der westen waffen liefert
letztendlich würde russland gewinnen
beides sind natürlich pro-russische
negative die so nicht stimmen
jetzt stellen sie ich habe es gerade
schon so ein bisschen gesagt man hat den
eindruck die russen stellen sich da so
als befreier als humanitäre helfer da
die den menschen eben in zerbombten
städten lebensmittel bringen die
brutalität des russischen angriff wird
aber eben überhaupt nicht gezeigt
wird überhaupt nicht gezeigt und
parallel dazu haben wir auch gesehen
dass in den letzten tagen russland am
seine kriegsführung noch mal verschärft
hat mit den angriffen auf große städte
mit zivilen opfer zahlen sehr hoch wie
nizza und auch und nico beispielsweise
und auch dass man eben
zeigt dass man rhetorisch die
eskalationsspirale anzieht in dem putin
ja auch gesagt hat man hätte noch gar
nicht richtig begonnen das sind auch
drohungen die sich an die ukraine wenden
aber sehr sehr stark auch auf das
westliche publikum
wenn so ein bisschen transportiert wird
die menschen sind ja zufrieden wenn wir
ja auch sehen da werden russische pässe
ausgegeben es werden fakten geschaffen
wenn das in die richtung so ein bisschen
geht nach dem motto seht auch mal her
die menschen wollen jetzt hier das nicht
mehr gekämpft wird eine rückeroberung
lasst es doch sein akzeptieren wir doch
so wie es ist mit anderen worten dass
der don was im grunde genommen in
russischer hand ist wenn man diesen
eindruck durch solche bilder sich eine
tour bekommt ist das wirklich zutreffen
dass putin dass russland sich also mit
dem don bass zufrieden gäbe oder steckt
doch mehr dahinter als wenn man sich die
ziele anguckt die putin selbst ja
genannt hat dann gehen die weit über den
don boscos er gesagt es geht darum dass
die ukraine demilitarisiert und
entnazifiziert werden würde was
letztendlich heißt dass die ukraine eine
andere politische führung ein anderes
politisches system nämlich ein
russischer autoritäres bekommen solle
und dass sie nicht nur zur
selbstverteidigung in der lage sei und
all diese ziele sind bisher ja nicht
erreicht und so kann man sagen dass der
donbass ein zwischenschritt ist für die
russische führung gehen wir nach innen
verkaufen kann als sozusagen kern dessen
was man gesagt hat aber die ziele gehen
viel viel weiter hinaus und von dem her
ist es ihr eine zwischenetappe
was bedeuten diese bilder wenn man so
suggeriert ja der don was ist doch in
unserer hand die menschen sind da auch
ganz zufrieden kann man sagen dass
kreiert für sie lenski auch ein gewisses
problem
es kreiert eigentlich eher für die
westliche debatte ein problem denn wir
können eigentlich davon ausgehen dass
die russische führung jetzt bis herbst
versuchen wird nochmal so viel boden wie
möglich zu gewinnen um dann richtung
herbst wenn in europa sich die debatte
vielleicht so ein bisschen stärker
richtung innenpolitische auswirkungen
des krieges verändern wird nämlich hohe
energiepreise vielleicht auch mögliche
migration der flüchtlingsströme wegen
nahrungsmittelknappheit dass man dann
sagen kann so in diesem moment jedoch
bitte schön hier ist es nicht sinnvoller
wir machen einen waffenstillstand zu
russischen bedingungen so dass der
westen dann genötigt werden würde auf
zielinski druck auszuüben dem
zuzustimmen aber man darf sich da keine
illusionen machen so ein
waffenstillstand bedeutet ja de facto
dann eigentlich eine festschreibung des
zustandes ja da ist nämlich der
russischen besatzung in einem wichtigen
teil der ukraine und das wäre dann eine
verfestigung dieses konfliktes von dem
aus russland dann vielleicht nach
monaten später wieder erneut stärker
eskalieren könnte militärisch
jetzt haben wir ja gesehen wie das uns
gezeigt es wurde den ja den teilnehmern
dieser tour wurden eben auch westliche
waffen gezeigt die erbeutet worden sind
über die müssen wir einfach über diese
bilder auf einmal sprechen aber es ist
halt zufällig heute so dass
eu-ratspräsident michelle in brüssel
nach beratungen der außenminister
angekündigt hat dass die eu die ukraine
mit weiteren 500 millionen euro für die
lieferung von waffen unterstützen will
diese 500 millionen euro zur verfügung
stellen will schauen wir uns erst einmal
ganz kurz einen überblick über die
militärische lage und eben auch die
rolle der waffen an
die ukraine ist fest entschlossen den
russischen aggressionen weiter stand zu
halten das ist auch dank westlicher
waffenlieferungen möglich ein
amerikanischer heimers raketenwerfer im
einsatz mit diesem modernen waffen
system ist die ukrainische armee
deutlich stärker weil die geschosse bis
zu 90 kilometer weit fliegen und sie
sind sehr präzise wo genau die
raketenwerfer operieren ist streng
geheim aus taktischen gründen sie haben
keine panzerung und können schnell
zerstört werden
auch die deutsche panzerhaubitze 2000
kommt in der ukraine zum einsatz ein 60
tonnen schwere artillerie system das
ebenfalls sehr weit feuern kann mit
diesen waffen sollen die kreml truppen
schon empfindlich getroffen worden seien
doch die wende im krieg haben sie
bislang nicht bringen können russland
hatte seine truppen in der ost ukraine
zuletzt vor allem umgruppiert
eine woche dann sondersitzungen der duma
die russische führung lässt gesetze
verabschieden die die umstellung der
russischen wirtschaft auf den kriegs
bedarf begleiten
am samstag dann der befehl von
verteidigungsminister schoigu die kämpfe
wieder zu verschärfen diese bilder
sollen ihn heute bei truppenbesuchen in
der ukraine zeigen mit der klaren
botschaft das russische militär solle
sich auf die zerstörung westlicher
waffen konzentrieren
ja und nun zeigt also das russische
militär die erbeuteten westlichen waffen
journalisten und eben auch unseren
kollegen warum machen die russen das was
wollen sie damit rüberbringen man möchte
sie ganz klar zeigen dass es angeblich
nicht helfen würde die ukraine zu
unterstützen dass russland insgesamt
stärker werde dass das dem krieg
eigentlich nur verlängern würde aber es
ist ja einen abnutzungskrieg in dem die
ukraine gegenhalten kann wenn sie die
waffen geliefert bekommt und das ja auch
sehr erfolgreich in vielen bereichen tut
und es geht darum dass wenn es seien
verhandlungen gibt die ukraine eine so
gute ausgangsposition hat wie möglich
also das ist sozusagen der versuch hier
russische negative zu verbreiten
ja jetzt fragt florians vater über
youtube passen wie sehen sie denn vor
lauter kleinen die chancen der ukraine
den krieg zu gewinnen in
anführungsstrichen also das hängt sehr
stark davon ab ob die ukraine moderne
waffensysteme bekommt dann das was sie
hat es in weiten teilen aufgebraucht und
sie ist darauf angewiesen dass jetzt
auch moderne westliche waffen kommen
einfach auch weil die munition
der bisherigen eher sowjetischen modelle
ja auch ausgeht von der moral und von
dem widerstandswillen ist die ukraine
immer noch sehr sehr weit dabei kämpfen
zu wollen und genau deswegen kommt es
darauf an dass man hier der russischen
seite auch entgegen hält und es ist ja
nicht so dass das alles auf russischer
seite glänzt was dort von schon gut im
verteidigungsminister gezeigt wird wir
sehen dass russland hohe verluste hat
bei soldaten offiziere und auch generäle
und das ist schon auf die sogenannte
stille mobilisierung zurückgreifen muss
also den versuch freiwillige zu
mobilisieren zu rekrutieren für die
russischen streitkräfte die überhaupt
nicht ausgebildet und dann in den kampf
gehen sollen ja was heißt das genau
stille mobilisierung also moskau muss
manpower generieren wie machen die das
eine generalmobilmachung das haben wir
gelernt versucht man ja sozusagen zu
vermeiden wie der teufel das weihwasser
also die möchte man wirklich aus
innenpolitischen gründen vermeiden weil
die eben aufgrund der erfahrungen in
afghanistan und tschetschenien eine
generalmobilmachung unwahrscheinlich
unpopulär werde und zweitens auch
dass sie auch ein problem wäre das was
man jetzt versucht ist eine stille
mobilisierung das heißt man setzt
anreize mit sehr holen soll zahlungen um
gerade in diesen eher ärmeren und
schwächeren regionen leute zu
mobilisieren
in die streitkräfte einzutreten die dann
30 tage
training bekommen oder indem man
beispielsweise söldner gruppierungen
verstärkt einsetzt die jetzt auch nach
verschiedenen berichten in gefängnissen
rekrutieren was ja dann auch wieder ein
teil von psychologischer kriegsführung
ist in dem eben sehr brutale personen
dann auch in die ukraine verfrachtet
werden sollen vor dem hintergrund von
butter oder ihre pin beispielsweise also
das wäre eher die stille mobilisierung
es gibt aber auch fälle von
zwangsrekrutierungen die berichtet
werden aus den besetzten gebieten in
dornbach wo männer vor ort zu dem
kriegsdienst auf russischer seite dann
zwangsverpflichtet werden
das erscheint mir jetzt eigentlich
äußerst brutal wenn man gezwungen und
wird dann gegen sozusagen die eigenen
freunde die die eigenen landsleute zu
kämpfen
absolute das ist ein teil auch von
psychologischer kriegsführung und es ist
ein teil der zeigen soll dass man hier
die kontrolle über dieses gebiet eben
auch hatte aber es zeigt auch wie schwer
offensichtlich die probleme personeller
art in den russischen streitkräften auch
sind dass man darauf zurückgreift haben
sie denn jetzt gibt es dafür beweise
gibt es jetzt irgendwie bildmaterial das
wurde natürlich jetzt eine
zwangsrekrutierung nicht unserem
kollegen wieder in werneck vorgeführt
also es gibt video material das gedreht
wird von von personen die davon sprechen
dass hier männer
angezogen werden würden und so weiter
also wie gesagt deswegen hatte ich ja
auch gesagt es gibt berichte dazu die
sich aber in dem was gezeigt werden
übereinstimmen
jetzt gibt es noch eine ganz konkrete
frage sie sind ja auch militär
expertinnen und wir haben eben in dieser
zusammenfassung über die lage und auch
die waffen dieser heimat gesehen high
mobility artillerie rocket systems
könnten fragt jetzt jemand über youtube
mit diesen heimat auch strategische
ziele in russland angegriffen werden von
den ukrainischen truppen und wenn ja
würde das militärisch sinn machen
also mit der munition die es im moment
haben eher unwahrscheinlich weil die
reichweite begrenzt ist wenn die
reichweite durch andere munition erhöht
werden würde ja es geht aber moment
darum dass die ukrainischen streitkräfte
in die lage versetzt werden ziele hinter
der frontlinie anzugreifen die gerade
für die vorbereitungen für eine große
offensive der russischen streitkräfte
wichtig sind also munitionsdepots
gefecht stände beispielsweise warenlager
infrastruktureinrichtungen um eben den
die schnelligkeit des russischen
vormarsches
gewisser weise reduzieren zu können das
ist eigentlich der sinn der davon jetzt
gemacht wird damit man die ukraine ist
artillerie technisch in der in der
unterlegenheit gegenüber dem was
russland noch auf zu bieten hat und
deswegen muss man hier mit quantität und
qualität auch versuchen zu kontern damit
die ukraine hier eine chance hat auch
diese firma stroetmann auch etwas
entgegen zu setzen kommt passen die
frage hier von files zu entlarven oder
2011 wie lange kann die ukraine den bei
dem aktuellen waffen volumen durchhalten
sie haben es ja gerade gesagt wie
wichtig es ist dass westliche waffen
kommen weil eben auch die munition
ausgeht von alten waffen sowjetischer
bauart aber wenn die waffen in dieser
geschwindigkeit geliefert werden wie es
momentan ist kann die ukraine dann
überhaupt durchhalten
es ist schwer da konkrete zahlen zu
geben weil es ja auch eine frage der
relation es wie viel kann russland
hinein wie viel macht man aber
man kann sie ja klar sagen dass mehr
geliefert werden muss um eben dieser
übermacht der russischen seite allein
von der quantität her etwas
entgegensetzen zu können also
beispielsweise heißt es immer dass die
ukrainische seite ungefähr vier bis 6000
granaten verschießen kann russland
20.000 am tagen nur mal so eine
größenordnung auch zu nennen
ja dann kommt man eigentlich zur letzten
frage die schwierig ist nämlich was ihr
ausblick ist kevin schmidt schreibt über
youtube passend wird putin sich
geschlagen geben wenn er zurückgedrängt
wird über die grenze das heißt welche
grenze müsste man dann schon nehmen
nimmt man die alte ukrainisch russische
grenze dann ist ja jede menge auch
zurückerobert werden und insofern ist
einfach die frage wie sehen sie das wie
wird sich dieser krieg weiterentwickeln
und parallel dazu denken jetzt an
wienand wernicke wie wird sich auch die
propagandaschlacht entwickeln
also es gibt eigentlich drei szenarien
das eine ist russland gelingt ein großer
vorstoß und die erreichung der
strategischen ziele dass es im moment
eher unwahrscheinlich weil die ukraine
sehr stark widerstand leistet und
solange waffenlieferungen da sind kann
es auch durchaus der russische format
deutlich verzögert werden oder
vielleicht zurückgeschlagen werden im
süden insbesondere das andere ist dass
die ukraine deutlich mehr lieferungen
bekommt und tatsächlich es ihr gelingen
würde weite teile der nach dem 24
februar obersten gebiete zurückzuerobern
das wäre dann eine sehr sehr gute
ausgangslage für mögliche verhandlungen
mit russland dass man über diese linie
des 24 2 hinaus dass zurückerobert was
russland seit 2014 annektiert hat oder
illegal besetzt hat erscheint mir im
moment eher unwahrscheinlich und was wir
in bezug auf westliche staaten zu
erwarten haben ist sicherlich nutzung
herbst hinein eine viel stärkere
sogenannte psychologische kriegsführung
operation oder den versuch durch
propaganda und desinformation eben die
innenpolitische debatte zu drehen dann
für putin ist eine schwäche westlicher
staaten diejenigen dass die dortigen
politiker auf die öffentliche meinung
rücksicht nehmen müssen und deswegen
versucht man ganz gezielt die
öffentliche meinung zu beeinflussen
wird von dort aus druck auf die firma
ausgeübt wird dass man sagt na ja es hat
eigentlich gar keinen sinn die ukraine
zu unterstützen ein schlechter
waffenstillstand sei besser als die
fortsetzung des krieges was aber
letztendlich nur russische gebiete und
russische gewinne konsolidieren würde
dann danken wir ganz ganz ganz herzlich
für diese analyse für ihre einschätzung
vielen dank frau dr klein grüße nach
berlin und ihnen einen schönen am tag
danach das war zdf heute live zum
ukraine krieg heute mit einem ganz
besonderen einblick geben einen
besonderen einblick durch die reise
unseres reporters wienand wernicke und
ich kann jetzt noch nach 7 kommentare
die wir bekommen haben
ein lob ein feedback an wienand wernicke
romantik schreibe youtube unter den
russen zu drehen war mit sicherheit
nicht ungefährlich hut ab also ein
kompliment und user 123 schreibt über
youtube danke für die berichterstattung
aus allen perspektiven das ist sehr
wichtig um zu zeigen dass es auch
grautöne zwischen der ganzen
schwarz-weiß
berichterstattung gibt also insofern
einen dank an wienand wernicke für diese
reise für diese perspektive die wir
bekommen haben und eben auch an frau dr
margarete klein für ihre analyse dazu
vielen dank für ihr interesse und
ebenfalls noch einen schönen abend